this is JR celebrating her 30th birthday
a milestone she didn't think she would
reach for most of her life she's been in
and out of treatment for an eating
disorder by the age of nine I had
developed anorexia nervosa which meant I
spent many subsequent years of my life
in hospital
this had a detrimental impact on every
aspect of my life including education
friendships family at the moment she's
been waiting 12 months for
community-based care and she's not alone
according to data provided exclusively
to Sky News of 19 NHS trusts providing
Community eating disorder Services
68 had waiting times exceeding three
months average waiting times from
referral to treatment stood at five
months and the longest waiting time
experience was 18 months
these delays in care can have
devastating consequences if you do not
treat these patients early their chances
of getting better decreases
significantly their chronicity increases
the chances of death increases massively
as well because eating disorder is a
multi-systematic disorder systemic
disorder meaning that it affects
patients
heart the brain the kidneys the lungs
and Bones experts say more targeted
funding would help reduce waiting times
in the current strain on NHS budgets
this government is serious about you
know reducing costs they need to put
forward an invest to save model which
actually invests in community care which
means that people get care in more of a
timely manner and don't become more
acute and put extra pressure on an NHS
which is already struggling in response
the government spokesperson told us
improving eating disorder Services is a
vital part of our work to bolster Mental
Health Services that's why we're
investing almost one billion pounds in
community mental health care for adults
with severe mental illness including
Eating Disorders by 2024 for now Jaya is
relying on support from her friends and
family but she fears with every day that
passes waiting for treatment and the
more likely it is her condition could
worsen Aisha zahid Sky News